[Musique]
jour de fête pour les apprentis de la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat de 16
à 25 ans ces jeunes ont côtoyé pendant 2
ans le monde de l'entreprise en
alternance avec celui de l'école Samuel
a réalisé sa formation au conseil
départemental pendant ces 2 ans on m'a
bien tutoré j'ai bien appris m'a bien
montré le monde du travail et j'ai la
chance d'être dans une très bonne équipe
c'est très important parce que acquérir
le BTS
c un
objectif céit c'est un niveau maintenant
c'est on va dire le niveau de base
comparé avant c'était le bas
et maintenant je vais pouvoir peut-être
continuer pour les licences mais je
préfère aller là travailler la
collectivité compte une vingtaine
d'apprentis de la Chambre des Métiers et
globalement plus de 200 jeunes d'autres
filières d'apprentissage sont intégré à
l'institution une bonne façon de
découvrir la diversité du monde
professionnel nous voici donc réunis à
nouveau pour honorer comme il se doit
les lauréas c'est une solution mais
c'est une bonne solution à mon avis
puisque vous savez que il y a de
l'alternance et quand on parle de
l'alternance il y a de l'expérience et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on recherche le CH
l'entreprise c'est aussi que la personne
qui arrive chez lui qui a un diplôme
mais il a aussi de l'expérience et je
crois que l'apprentissage a monté
vraiment ses capacités puisque
aujourd'hui le le taux d'insertion est
très important puisque dans certaines
sections la séation est totale c'estd
100 % dans d'autres un peu moins mais je
veux dire que quand même c'est une voix
intéressante dans la salle 530 jeunes
plein d'espoir avec leur diplôme en
poche les 5 universités régionales des
métiers de l'artisanat ancien CFA
dispense 91 diplômes du CAP au BTS avec
des les bas malheureusement comme comme
dans tout métiers mais
après mes baisse pas les brasura pas de
problème tous les jours on apprend
et quand quand on veut on peut ben ça
m'a appé beaucoup de choses dans le
métier ben la réalisation vraiment
apprendre le métier est meilleur
franchement l'école est meilleur et ben
l'entreprise après ben c'est plus le
sérieux qu' faut grader làbas pas une
camarade des mes différents mais quand
quand on aime bien ce métier là ben
c'est assez facile des adapterin
il veut dire quoi il faut sur le bon
métier ouais sur bon métier sur bonne
entreprise et déjà cette formation vu
qu'on est en entreprise de semaines et
une semaine à l'école donc on a beaucoup
de pratique on est dans le milieu du
travail donc voilà on a meilleure
compétences kevin est la première
personne à mobilité réduite de l'urma de
Saint-Paul pourtant le bâtiment peut
accueillir ce public depuis plus de 20
ans de quoi encourager ce
cursus les deétablissement sont ouvert
et tous
les de l sont sont
maintenant équipés pour
recevoir voilà donc il faut moi je pense
qu'il faut que les les jeunes à mobilité
réduite se Mobilis et et se disent on a
des centres pour nous accueillir on peut
faire de l'apprentissage les entreprises
sont prêts à les accueillir pour pour la
formation il les adapte les postes de
travail donc je pense qu'il faut frapper
tous n'uront pas le même avenir tion de
l'entreprise nouvelle formation ou
encore mobilité les acteurs de la
réussite de cette nouvelle génération
ont pris le temps de fêter cette
promotion de quoi inciter des
[Musique]
vocations